should you follow your heart
or follow your brain it's a question i
got recently from one of my youtube
viewers raj
who was wondering whether he should
follow his heart and start a family
business
or follow his brain and go after
computer engineering and wanted my
advice on what to do
it's a common question thanks for
writing in raj and really
if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur or otherwise
you have to embrace the genius of the
end
and don't position it as following your
heart
or following your brain combine it
you're following your heart and your
brain and find a way to make that work
if you love computer science but you're
also torn between doing that and doing
your business
the family business bring computer
science to your family business
combine it when you can do everything
that you love doing and pour yourself
into your company
that's when you're going to have success
if you're just taking over family
business and you do the things
that your parents did and it's the same
old thing you're not going to have huge
success as an entrepreneur
it may flatline you know you may start
seeing a little bit of a decline
the way that company is going to grow is
by you bringing more of yourself to the
company
when your parents or whoever in your
family started this business they had a
passion for
it they poured themselves into it and it
started to take off
the reason why so many businesses fail
when they get to multi-generation is
because the new generation tries to do
things the same way the old generation
did it
they're not putting themselves into that
business you have to shake it up
make it your own bring your passion to
it
and then it's going to achieve huge
success
if you love computer science you have to
bring that to your business
you'll have more fun you'll feel like
you're going to work energized
you'll bring more of yourself to the
company and you'll have much bigger
results
here's an example from my life i love
business i love entrepreneurship
i love famous entrepreneurs in their
success story
and i love dancing i do a lot of salsa
dancing
i'm dancing i'm djing i'm doing that 20
25 hours a week
it's a good part-time job doing dancing
and i can keep it as separate
you know here's evan the businessman and
then evan
the salsa guy but the real
power comes from combining that
so i've invested into a salsa company
and i'll dj there
and i bring my knowledge of business to
help that company and i bring my
knowledge of salsa
and dancing and art to help my business
i'm more fulfilled i'm happier and i
have more success
in my business life because i brought
more of myself to what i do
so empower and embrace the genius of the
end
don't force yourself to pick between
this and this
that are both important to you the real
power the real connection is going to
come
from combining those and you'll have
much
greater success in whatever you end up
doing
believe for those of you watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below it makes you want to do more
for you
and i'd love to hear what you have to
think about this video please leave a
comment underneath
and if you have a question for your own
business leave in the comment section
below and i will make a video response
for you guys thank you for tuning in and
i'll see you soon